they abstained in the u.n security
council they did not condemn russia's
invasion and this is key because
chinese foreign policy one of their key
pillars is non-intervention so changing
borders through force is anathema to the
chinese communist party so the fact that
they were able to try to overlook this
speaks volumes about the type of
relationship between russia and china
some analysts tried to spin it as a
positive thing but i don't think it's a
positive thing whatsoever because this
really goes against
the tradition they use the same language
as russia does they don't call it an
invasion they don't call it a war we're
seeing magnification of russian
propaganda by chinese so we haven't seen
that before so this is another watershed
moment
this kind of solidified their ontant
their agreement they both have a very
anti-western view anti-us view and in
this agreement we shouldn't overlook it
and they clarified that
they are supporting each other and for
the first time beijing
highlighted that they are against nato
after that agreement was inked uh
president putin was able to move his
troops which are in the far east
russia all the way to ukraine so this
could only be done with the tasted
support of china
[Music]
china's trying to say yes we can be a
peacemaker but no one's seeing any
evidence of that at all so i think that
it's a handy narrative it's a nice way
to recast them because it wasn't very
long ago the olympics in china were
boycotted because of genocide
accusations of crimes against humanity
and xinjiang so i see why that's an
attractive narrative for them
[Music]
they see that there's a danger here
because trade with russia is about 147
billion trade with europe is about 650
billion so it's more important to them
their european markets they don't want
to lose the support of the europeans and
also trade with the u.s it's a huge
market for china as well so they they
have to walk kind of a diplomatic
tightrope with supporting putin because
they have these common interests where
they overlap and they both have this
anti-western narrative and they like to
undermine the u.s together they had
perhaps expected a quick lightning speed
event in ukraine similar to what
happened in 2014 but it's a country of
41 million people it's likely to be long
and protracted and
they will have to worry about getting
dragged into
this narrative of condoning
or being complicit
with the invasion of a country that was
unprovoked so i think that this is a
danger for china
[Music]
you